bonsoir pierre connais ça merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france donc
cette plainte
on en parlait ce qu'il ya vraiment une
réelle volonté de sanction à l'encontre
d'un bs ou bien est ce tout simplement
symbolique
écoutez d'abord il ya un règlement de
comptes interaméricain c'est à dire que
effectivement l'une des premières
décisions de ben laden c'est de montrer
que la différence de 1 lui est capable
de présenter au peuple américain la
réalité la vérité donc ça c'est un point
très important puisque vous savez que
trump et état d'être assez loin dans
l'ignominie donc il ya cette dimension
là qui est à mon avis la plus importante
pour ce qui concerne la relation avec
l'arabie saoudite le pays cette fois je
pense pas qu'il va être la relation va
être très profondément déstabilisé le
premier acte café by dad c'est de
s'adresser directement au roi puisque
vous savez que moi même maître salman
n'est que le prince héritier et donc de
s'adresser aux pères de mbs pour lui
dire écoute et votre cas mais là il
faudrait peut-être un voyant colonies de
vacances et le faire disparaître pendant
quelque temps mais je ne crois pas que
ça va déstabiliser fondamentalement la
relation avec l'arabie saoudite alors en
tout cas un rapport des services de
renseignement américains déclassifiés 1
par l'administration bei den elles
montrent que l'assassinât du journaliste
n'a pu se faire sans l'aval de mbs
c'est donc très grave et effectivement
ça vous semble cohérent
abbas est complètement cohérent ce sont
les plus proches conseillers qui ont
probablement assassiné et découpé en
morceaux et jamal khashoggi aime le plus
extraordinaire c'est que ces gens étant
identifié grâce au service turc puisque
vous savez que les turcs avaient
complètement sonorisé le consulat
saoudien il semble donc ils savent
parfaitement qui a fait quoi
ils ont donc fourni cette liste et en
dépit de ce que raconte effectivement
l'arabie saoudite disant qu'un certain
nombre des conseillers ont été condamnés
est intéressant c'est ce qu'ils ont été
amnistiés par mois m salvador qu'ils
étaient dans le commando al qahtani
qu'elles sont conseillés son âme damnée
le général assez aride et le chef des
renseignements ceux là ont été amnistiés
ça veut dire que probablement le régime
a peur qu'ils parlent alors vous vous
disiez tout à l'heure que vous goûtiez
finalement que ça change profondément
la relation entre les états unis et
l'arabie saoudite que l'animation baden
préféré dialoguer avec le roi il
n'empêche le président américain a
également décidé d'arrêter de soutenir
militairement le royaume c'est tout de
même une décision important pourquoi ce
changement de stratégie
écoutez il faut distinguer le candidat
américain en campagne le candidat
américain ou aux postes de
responsabilité rappelez vous que le
travail fait sa campagne électorale
on est dense à l'argent saoudien dans la
foulée maison blanche son premier voyage
officiel se fait en arabie saoudite pour
by donne quand il est candidat et
dis-moi j'arrêterai des ventes d'armes à
l'arabie saoudite mais enfin je ne crois
pas une minute que si vous voulez il va
arrêter de vendre des armes à l'arabie
saoudite non le point sensible c'est la
guerre ou yémen qu'est ce que vous savez
que les américains fournissent les
données de ciblage pour que les avions
saoudiens probable c'est que c'est une
campagne aérienne essentiellement du
côté de l'arabie saoudite et donc c'est
s'ils arrêtent de fournir les données de
ciblage étant donnée la maladresse dans
les saoudiens ont fait preuve jusqu'à
maintenant je sais pas si ça va servir à
grand chose parce qu'ils ont tiré sur
une école sur un hôpital de msf et des
choses comme ça donc tout dépend de ce
que contient cette affirmation disant
qu'il va arrêter de collaborer avec
l'arabie saoudite moi je personnellement
je n'y pense pas je pars je crois qu'ils
ont des cartes aura un mois m ben salman
n'oubliez pas que l'on m'a quand même
pas mal d'ennemis à l'intérieur il a
pris tous ses petits camarades à l'hôtel
ritz il les a plus mais d'un milliard de
dollars chacun donc il a fait derrière
lui il a laissé derrière lui des gens
qui sont très mécontents et qui sont des
princes la famille royale donc est ce
que le fait de l'écarter du pouvoir va
probablement faire beaucoup de plaisir
on dans l'entourage de la dynastie
saoudienne ya quand même des villes
prince sur ce contexte de guerre au
yémen que vous venez de nous décrire
quel doit être le rôle de laura aux
parents c'est que il ya guère que
l'allemagne
l'italie qui ont arrêté de vendre des
armes à la radio le son vous pouvez à
votre question oui sur concernant ce que
vous nous dire sur le gros souci si la
liaison est toujours bonne avec pierre
connaît ça vous entendez sur le contexte
que vous venez de nous décrire de la
guerre au yémen il ya l'allemagne et
l'italie qui ont été de vendre les armes
à l'arabie saoudite qu'elle doit être
aujourd'hui selon vous la position de la
france beaucoup de voix s'élèvent pour
justement demandé le contrôle des armes
de la part du parlement pour justement
sais c'est qu'on vend des armes à
l'arabie saoudite
oui bah écoutez c'est très bien
qu'effectivement il ya en france
quelques voix qui s'élèvent on est
encore une fois que on peut arrêter de
fournir les armes qui servent à la
guerre au liban
bon cela dit vous savez tout ça est une
affaire de ce bal des hypocrites parce
qu'on leur vend des camions césar vous
savez des canons caesar son des canons à
longue portée guidés par gps etc
si vous les laissez du côté de
saoudiennes de la frontière vous pouvez
expliquer que c'est des armes défensives
même si vous tirez sur le yémen vous
savez il ya une espèce de deux manières
de 2 comment dire de jouer l'hypocrisie
pour continuer à fournir
même en situation de conflit en phase
iib la france ça donnera une leçon
probablement importante encore une fois
un pays qui jusqu'à maintenant n'a
jamais reçu n'oubliez pas qu'après le 11
septembre quand je bush accuse l'iran
l'irak et la corée du nord est pas leurs
habits scpi dont il était tellement
habitués à ce qu'on les tient donc on
les préserve pour les protège mais si
effectivement pour cette fois y ait un
rapport mais l'union européenne qui pèse
parfois que mon impression félicité il
ya nous avions votre place responsables
des ong à un benoît murs à ciel qui nous
expliquait que peu de médias français
faisait état de cette guerre au yémen et
les armes la question des armes à qui on
les vendait pourquoi comment vous vous
l'expliquez comment cette absence de ce
sujet dans la presse française
ben c'est plutôt avoue qu'il faudrait
poser la question moi ce que je connais
c'est le côté exportations d'armements
ses volets l'arabisme oui je comprend
l'arabie saoudite est le premier client
de la france si vous voulez en moyenne
lissée sur les trente dernières années
c'est à dire c'est le pays auquel on a
vendu le plus si on ramène si vous les
feuilles moyen de 39
donc c'est un client qui se respecte ce
c'est quand même quelque chose de très
abondantes retard c'est un pays qui a
par le passé s'ils voulaient rendu des
services rappelez vous que quand
mitterrand en est à sa 3ème d'évaluation
on en voit d'autres misent de l'économie
et des finances en arabie saoudite pour
leur demander de parrot qui est réel
vous avez vous des points de presse pour
éviter une troisième d'évaluation donc
c'est un pays avec lequel si vous voulez
encore une fois il faut réfléchir à deux
fois avant de prendre une décision trop
systématique et le fait que la frôle un
lag mendiants le fait que le la presse
ne parle pas de la guerre au yémen
je signale qu'il ya 400 crise à la
surface de la planète la question
pourquoi dans les rédactions on va
choisir texte a guère que d'autres
pilotes
et effectivement la question ce n'est
pas vers vous c'est que vous voulez vous
faire au yémen d'un certain c'est une
espèce de pays que personne ne connaît
véritablement on a de très bons
spécialistes de la question
mais allez vous convaincre un patron de
journal de faire une sur la guerre au
yémen
non encore une fois c'est la dimension
médiatique qui fait l'importance d'une
guerre il faudrait en gage auprès des
journaux pour la demander pourquoi la
garonne ne l'intéresse pas n'y a pas
d'image donc il n'y a pas d'image
il n'y a pas de guerre la guerre au
yémen était pourtant l'une des pires
crises humanitaires selon l'onu merci en
tout cas pierre connais ça d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur les france où
nous avoir apporté votre analyse